concrete pipes stacked up in a field
what could be mistaken for a
construction site is actually part of a
modern villa named the a/b house
architect andreas vadas lives here with
his family welcome to our house please
come in 360 concrete pipes normally used
in road construction provide shade while
letting in plenty of light to the
interior decor is simple and functional
the open-plan kitchen and living area
form the heart of the house the couple
has been living in this 190 square metre
home in perforce on the west coast of
Cyprus since 2016 we have this
simplicity not only in the interior as a
decoration but it's a lifestyle
you know always believe that when you
come home you must like clear yourself
from the thought of the day from the
thought of your job from there from the
everyday outdoor the most important
elements of a sliding glass walls most
sides of the house can be opened up like
this creating an extra 150 square metres
of living space
for us this space is very important the
connection between in and out is like in
the summer period which is eight months
it's going to be a place where you
entertain a pleasure you have
exhibitions a place that you die in a
place at you is like the living room for
you it's like you move the living room
from inside to outside
[Music]
I'm going to show you now a special
feature for the house and race vadas
wanted to be able to use the space in a
variety of ways so he designed these
moveable bookshelves
we wanted to create a different kind of
space like we use for the whole house
like in and out so the idea of like you
can closer the this space and it becomes
a room we didn't want to make a room we
wanted to have a space that if we close
it to become a room so if we don't want
it closed we don't want that privacy
it's an open-plan area related to the
external the water corridor on the
northern side of the building is not
just for show the babbling sound of
water creates a relaxing environment and
in the summer the water cools the air
acting as a natural air conditioner for
the bedroom the winds are blowing by
opening the the South window it creates
the stack effects the movement of the
air this figure it gives us the the
feeling of two to three degrees let's
drop down at the same time reduce the
humidity level
the concrete pipes form the outer walls
of the homes two longest sides
it's a wall with holes in it but it
shields inhabitants from both curious
onlookers and the son
every minute the Sun moves away around
it's just you to create inside or
outside the different experiences and
different light experiences and
architecture is about the game of light
Cyprus is warm climate and andreas
father sees a bee house make for a
winning combination